this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you know
this you know the cash app it's a
simplest way to instantly send money to
friends I use it all the time that's all
I use it's also the number one app in
finance but it didn't get there on
payments alone these days cash app is
changing how people interact with their
money it's adding features so you can
only get it's adding features you can
only get from a bank and more than a few
that you can like the cash card boosts
and Bitcoin I use this app all the time
it's the best app to pay people back get
the cash app it's so simple they don't
have a history of what you do on there
you can just pay people back immediately
and nobody knows download the cash app
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market we did it folks
and you know what I do now I do this
thing that's a bros do I do this
sometimes I do a few you know I mean and
I have the fire tattoo so I'll go and
then ago and it pisses my friends off so
much but I don't give a [ __ ] dude
we're live on my app we're live on my
app and you can be live on my app and
and listen and watch the podcast first
it's okay if it happens the dogs
throwing up one fires dog is throwing
the [ __ ] up straight-up came over and
just throwing up why do dogs throw up so
much hey dogs stop eating all of this
[ __ ] around oh it sucks to throw up dude
how violent is it to throw up
he's really working on a big throw up
there we go nice good boy
Ivan or uh one fires dog just through
the wait no that's Ivan get rid of dog
they all look the same by the way one
fire has dogs and Ivan gets rid of has a
dog and they're all the same they are
all white [ __ ] little skinny ass
scrawny [ __ ]
but yeah so we're good man we're good to
go
episode 81 and I'm live on the app here
so download my app on the on where you
can get apps and then we can we can
watch the podcast earlier than anybody
else so yeah I've been in LA for a while
man I'm going on the road I'm going to
Wichita I'm going to Kansas City and I'm
going to link in Nevada and that's
what's up
now I had a whole thing that I wanted to
talk about up front but the dog [ __ ]
threw up now I completely forget about
what happened what it was
dude when dogs throw up one time up my
old dog when I was a kid his name was
Cody he died of cancer dude and but he
was cute he was a golden retriever and
and he was he he ate a decent piece of
broccoli that my there was like a person
that was like helping out I don't know
what happened we were such terrors that
my mom and my dad got somebody had to
help out cuz my dad was always working
and her name was Rachel and she gave the
dog a broccoli and the dog the dog ate
it
Cody ate it and I was like you shouldn't
give the dog broccoli and she's like
it's fine and then the dog just started
going and then threw out the broccoli
and it was like a bunch of throw up with
a piece of broccoli on top of it it was
so weird yeah but uh yeah so that's what
that's what happened and then I and then
one time I called her [ __ ] pizza face
and I always think about it and I feel
so [ __ ] bad about it because she said
she got she when she moved to LA she got
she broke out I was like [ __ ] 12
years old and I called her pizza face
and she was like that really hurt my
feelings and it made me feel so [ __ ]
bad and I still feel bad about that
she's probably [ __ ] 50 right now and
I
I still think about that I called her
Pizza face [ __ ] man
you know illa takes is a moment and then
you regret something for the rest of
your life you know and then when she
left she told me that she didn't like
how my brother Matt treated her a lot
because he was like a bad kid or
whatever not a bad kid but like whatever
and then Matt said man she said she she
never liked the way you treated her to
me and I was like what the [ __ ] she said
that about you and then so now there's
like an ongoing fight constantly about
how Rachel didn't like either of us and
I'm 38 years old and now there's an
ongoing fight about how rachel liked me
better or Rachel liked him better
anyway I do it the dog [ __ ] threw up
broccoli like throw up with a piece of
broccoli on top of it like it was a
[ __ ] like it was on beat Bobby Flay
like it was a sweet piece of broccoli on
a on a throbs like yeah we got we got
throw up but and the broccoli but the
throw up is the vehicle for the broccoli
it really it really takes the flavor to
another level it acts it accents the
flavor I like Tabasco sauce dude that's
what I like all right if you're gonna
[ __ ] throw hot sauce at me oh let me
tell you the most me [ __ ] all right I
like Tabasco sauce and that's the hot
sauce I like when somebody [ __ ]
throws Tapatio or chalupa get the [ __ ]
out of here dude when you're like hey do
you have Tabasco sauce and the and the
restaurant comes by and they'll and they
bring chalupa ah dude that's not what I
asked for
ah ha oh dude you brought a different oh
it's Cholula not chalupa chalupa is a
[ __ ] Mexican dish right some racist
great some racist Cholula dude when they
bring Cholula or Tapatio even though you
ask for [ __ ] Tabasco and they bring
tapa the-- yeah dude that's [ __ ]
stop Athiya I don't want [ __ ] Tapatio
because I asked for I asked for what do
you call it the [ __ ] Tabasco dude
drives me nuts bring me a shoebox
bring me a shoebox instead because
that's that's not that's not Tabasco
either I would have mad respect for a if
they were like oh you wanted Tabasco
sauce okay cool and then they brought a
shoebox and then put it down I said what
the [ __ ] is this and they said this is
sorry you wanted you wanted Tabasco
sauce and I said oh but what the [ __ ]
and they say well yeah but we don't have
Tabasco sauce so we brought the next
thing closest to it oh but that's not
that yeah I know but a lot of
restaurants bring Cholula and and we
don't like that they do that so we
brought a shoebox and because that's not
that either and we're on board with your
Chris D'Elia and then me and that person
joined forces and then we become the
president and the vice president that's
how the world works now dude Jesus am i
high I don't even know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about everybody tries to make
something out of nothing dude I was I
was looking at Twitter at this Nicki
Minaj thing how she dropped an album by
the way I guess artists think it's
[ __ ] awesome to just drop an album
with no promo like it's the new hot [ __ ]
and remember when Beyonce did it she was
like whoopsie there's an album out today
didn't tell anybody and she broke the
internet quote-unquote like fine alright
so Nicki Minaj came out with an album
and she came out with this [ __ ] song
where she's just like lightly jabbing
and playing and joking about all the
other rappers and everyone's like oh she
[ __ ] she called out these are the
people she called out and they just list
everybody it's not a diss song dude
she's just [ __ ] around and everyone's
like uh Nicki Minaj dissed everybody no
she's not what is she a lunatic what
does she have [ __ ] I don't the
Twitter moments are just like it's just
like it's like Aziz Ansari bought a
sandwich in in Greenwich Village and
then you look at it and it's like Aziz
Ansari [ __ ] tweets bought a sandwich
and then somebody else is like has a
picture of Aziz Ansari by buying a
sandwich Twitter moments more shits
happening dude
what's a Family Guy the other night it's
so funny it's it's act today I'm family
guys funny show on TV
III thought it was maybe alone together
that shows so [ __ ] funny
but dude Family Guy he's so funny man
the jokes that they have is like dang
get it down get it down get a dangler
dangler they never stop joking dude what
are you doing it's fine
what do you hear what uh an echo Oh God
such a [ __ ] this chairs making noise
like a [ __ ] an x-men sonar one fires
like this chairs making noise I can tell
this chairs making noise worst x-men
ever dropped out of a [ __ ] Professor
Xavier school just like Professor Xavier
is like we don't really have much use
for you
you just can hear chairs it's like I can
hear yours
it moves yeah who cares man nobody's
gonna be able to tell at home that the
chairs echoey yeah so what was what was
I talking about [ __ ] was I talking
about before you start moving chairs
around dude one fire you're the dog
threw up you're moving the chair dude
I'm trying to get on up [ __ ] and I keep
having a switch [ __ ] cuz he's just
moving chairs around like a [ __ ]
lunatic Family Guy dude gotta watch this
episode [ __ ] it's so funny what Peter
Griffin is the funniest character on a
TV in in history dude his stupid laugh
and his [ __ ] eye kid dude I have the
worst memory of all time I
I have the worst memory of all time I
forget what I'm talking about when I'm
talking about it we're gonna get on this
[ __ ] podcast though dude um we're
gonna get on this podcast and it's Sun I
have [ __ ] 40 dogs at my house right
now it's just a little distracting but I
still want to be here for your babies
and it's on dude but I had a anyway I
did so many shows I did a benefit
whatever dude I don't give a [ __ ] man
dude you guys are with me to the end
let's [ __ ] ride you know what I was
thinking about actually you know who
would win for to win who would win
president see who would win the [ __ ]
presidency if he ran is joe rogan if he
ran for president he would he would win
hands down there's no way he wouldn't
win he is the exact kind of guy that
would win right now you know why you
know what we need for a presidency you
know who you know who would win anybody
who could knock Trump out that's who
would win a man you know we need a man
you know and look I'll tell you like I'm
all for a female president but I feel
like the country right now is so sour on
that [ __ ] that you know with what
happened with I think we need to [ __ ]
put all our cards to stack the deck and
just pick a [ __ ] white guy you know
what I mean and and just get that guy in
and [ __ ] a guy who could knock Trump
out physically you know and he would and
and and a good debate or two drogon
would kill it Rogen would be first of
all he argues he's a great arguer he's a
great debater he's an alpha he could
knock Trump out you don't know what side
he's on you don't know if he's a
Democrat or Republican which is great I
guess he'd have to pick maybe he could
run as an independent I don't know but
like he also is also could humiliate
Trump with funny with with being a
comedian dude I'm telling you Rogen if
he ran for presidency he would win and I
think he would win by a landslide - I'm
gonna [ __ ] ask him about it I'm gonna
text him about it that's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna [ __ ] ask him to run for
presidency
imagine that
Rogan and then Joey Diaz as vice
president you know [ __ ] yeah man I
think that that would be the [ __ ] I was
reading the story the other day about
this guy I forget what story it was but
he was um he was he was um he did
something against the law and then he
turned himself in because he felt bad
dude
here's the thing man if you do something
that's bad and then you feel too guilty
you got to eat that [ __ ] that becomes
cancer in you and you die period you
don't get to [ __ ] feel guilty and
absolve yourself by admitting it if you
kill someone and they die and they don't
know who it is
you don't turn yourself in because you
[ __ ] make that become cancer in you
and you die a slow death that's what
happens man you were selfish enough to
kill somebody you don't get to be not
selfish enough to tell somebody and
admit it and feel better about yourself
because you absolved yourself and you
started the road to you know whatever
the [ __ ] remember that movie Road to
Perdition or whatever the [ __ ] dude
here's you know what movie I never want
to go see any movie that were there's
too much Brown in it here are the things
I never want to say too much brown and
grey in a movie whether it's hats and
[ __ ] suits and and forests or logs
you know oh that was that Tom Hanks
movie what's the other like you know
Vincent Viggo Mortensen is always in
these movies where there's like there's
too much Brown does maybe a horse in it
there's too many beards I don't like
movies where there's too many guys with
beards in it too much Brown if there's a
[ __ ] like any kind of guy if there's
a guy who's like a hobbit or a [ __ ]
tall giant I don't I want everyone to be
regular-sized I want everyone to be
regular-sized I want there to be colors
in the movie I don't want it to be too
much Brown I don't want there be too
many beards I don't want there to be a
guy with a staff you know what I mean I
don't want any
those [ __ ] things I don't want
old-time cars old-timey cars period
pieces dude chicks love period pieces
you know what girl what movies are girls
favorite movies any movie that has to do
with not today I swear to God if you
make a movie in 1920 chicks will flock
to it all you need is a girl that does
this kind of [ __ ] and then you're gonna
have to see the video podcast for this
but a girl that talks like this any any
kind of girl that talks like this it's
like ha yes but that's what he said
ha ha ha ha any kind of girl that acts
like that in any movie girls will flock
to that and if they [ __ ] are in a
relationship if that movie if that girl
in that movie is in a relationship we're
the guys controlling forget it dude
forget it and then they meet another
like classy type type guy that like
steals her away from that guy for get it
flat fat dude I'm telling you girls love
movies that take place in the 1930s or
1920s or 1910s or earlier than that any
time earlier than that or 40s 50s 60s
70s even and now 80s and 90s even dude
cuz they love to [ __ ] remember the
time they love to remember the time
nothing the girls like doing more than
remember the time dude
Oh remember when and dudes love movies
about the future or now but dude if you
get a dude that's like I love Road to
Perdition that dude is a straight-up
[ __ ] any guy Road to Perdition is a bad
example you know it's a good example any
movie were a girl like girl with the
Pearl Earring if a guy liked that movie
I don't give a [ __ ] how good that movie
is so much Brown in that movie what's up
why did it how come color only came into
the [ __ ] I feel I mean I know I feel
like color really took off in like the
[ __ ] sixties what was that why would
there's an email thing go off
just my no reason my house is going fool
yeah did it's fine man um oh is my
computer I love I I don't I don't ever
want to go see a period piece but I want
to be in one for sure no doubt that will
be so gangster if I was in a girl with
the Pearl Earring imagine that dude
Scarlett Johansson or whatever I think
is in it and she walks in and she's like
where's you know chilling with her Pearl
Earring and then I walk in and I'm like
lazio Pearl Earring with a [ __ ] high
as Beethoven collar I mean I know a guy
that looked like Beethoven once and it
was [ __ ] all I could think of she had
like bitch-ass [ __ ] Beethoven hair
symphony hair you ever see a guy with
that [ __ ] Symphony hair that's just
like it's like so big and like cut it
dude I don't you know what and you
really do have symphony here I don't
have Symphony hair I have [ __ ] hockey
player hair that's what I have Symphony
hair is that why you bitch-ass [ __ ]
that's like poofy it would look good
with like a ruffle to white collar I
don't have that [ __ ] Symphony hair
that [ __ ] yes Symphony hair dude
imagine a guy just playing piano just
Papa and then it gets to where the curls
were in front because he's he's killing
the piano so hard that the [ __ ] hair
the pouf gets undone and then it and
then it starts to fallen over his eye I
mean dude that poofy ass hair is just
God like that [ __ ] who's the [ __ ]
that what was the movie they made about
with Michael Douglas and Matt Damon
where they played the Liberace is that
what that was yeah that [ __ ] ass hair
that's what we gotta get behind the
candelabra whatever a [ __ ] candelabra
is
I will watch any movie Michael Douglas's
in that dude first of all let me tell
you right now Michael Douglas in that
movie there is n there is nobody male or
female in that movie behind the
candelabra Michael Douglas in that movie
there is nobody male or female
old or young that looks more like my
[ __ ] grandma
then Michael Douglas in that movie
Michael Douglas looks so much like my
grandma Carmela in that [ __ ] movie
it's unreal dude I can't as a matter of
fact you ever like meet two people that
are two that like look like each other
and then when you're not with them you
can't think of what one of them looks
like cuz you keep thinking of the other
one dude when I I can't think of my
grandma Carmela when I look what and
after I look at Michael Douglas in that
movie for too long I can't [ __ ] look
away and think of my grandma Carmela and
she passed away but I can't mean did I I
swear to God if one scene of behind the
candelabra was was filmed with instead
of Michael Douglas if they used and if
they only use some wide shots and not
some close-ups if they use my grandma
Carmela nobody would [ __ ] know dude
how funny would that be if one if in one
scene there was just a grandma instead
of [ __ ] Michael Douglas
why don't [ __ ] [ __ ] why don't they do
[ __ ] like that I dude everything takes
itself so [ __ ] seriously man why
don't they do [ __ ] I wanna make a movie
where one scene just as somebody's
grandma for no reason I get [ __ ] I
want to do a movie with Vin Diesel and
then just bring a grandma in for one
scene I [ __ ] this is the [ __ ] I think
about all day all day I'll spend [ __ ]
20 minutes thinking about how I could
get a grandma and a Vin Diesel movie and
have Vin Diesel not be in it all day bro
haha Wow dude I [ __ ] love life man I
woke up sad today though man
but dude my moods shift like
unbelievably
it's crazy I woke up sad and now I'm
[ __ ] now I'm not now I'm poppin now
I'm on and poppin it's better than
coming I'm coming in today I'm coming in
tonight
um yeah dude you know what I realized
something about myself cuz I I just
sometimes get lost in thought I realized
something about myself and this is the
truth
dude I I am the I I don't like like I
saw a picture of [ __ ] Drake playing
basketball with me gose and their faces
looked away to serious and it's just
like hey guys don't be that serious and
play basketball and I was thinking about
how I don't like basketball and I don't
like things like that and I was thinking
about like games and [ __ ] and I was
thinking about why it bothers me that
people like basketball so much cuz it
shouldn't its I should just they should
just play basketball and I should not
give a [ __ ] about it or I should be like
oh good they're having fun playing
basketball but it's gotta be something
within me that I don't like that I don't
like about myself if I'm watching people
play basketball and it annoys me that
much now I'm not talking about the
Lakers the Celtics the [ __ ]
Thundercats or whatever the [ __ ] these
[ __ ] names are okay I'm talking
about guys in their 30s that just take
it too seriously when they're not
basketball players all right mm-hmm
and if they hit a jumper and then feel
good about it
you know also me goes you know playing
with the choir who is it playing with
that long ass hair and [ __ ] I just I was
thinking about why it bothers me lay and
it doesn't like it's not like I'm like
really grinded up about it I'm just like
why why they poke
I don't like I I don't like anything for
me that distracts me from being myself
right like I want to always be being me
okay this is why I love stand-up unless
it's in a funny way like I do want to be
in action movies [ __ ] that give me a gun
I want to go like this hey hey hey
that's my [ __ ] Gaul to be in a movie
hey hey hey
Oh put it down put it down put it down
put it down I want to say that so many
times over and over again until the
world of light why didn't they [ __ ]
cut some of that out and then this one
goes like this cuz it's real it's like
how it would really happen because
that's funny to me but like I don't want
to be distracted from anything that's me
right so like if somebody's gonna be
like hey have a basketball and play
basketball like I gotta stop thinking
about all the things I think of during
the day and distract myself and play
[ __ ] basketball no I want to be the
most me I can [ __ ] possibly be at all
times dude and you want to play frisbee
[ __ ] outta here on me dude it's like
that Lil Wayne song on me that song is I
know it's a highly-rated song but even
though it's so highly rated it's still
underrated [ __ ] are me that song
was the [ __ ] that's my mom that's my
song I'm me like I Paradis and there's
gonna be an
first some angry but yeah I want to be
the most me so good the way is this [ __ ]
I love Lil Wayne is the president he
said such a lie you know but I'm me dude
I don't want to I don't want to do
anything that this now granny I'll go
see movies or whatever the [ __ ] but like
I'd I see movies so I can [ __ ] think
about him and afterwards and I could
like come up with opinions about it but
I don't want to like play a [ __ ] game
dude
one time I was always a laughing with a
friend I we were I was with three dudes
I was with three people okay laughing
laughing laughing well I was with a dude
in a chick
so laugh and laugh and me and the dude
and the chick laughing so hard look so
[ __ ] harder than the girl goes like
this
you know I'll play this game that made
my boyfriend play all the time and we
were like what and we start playing the
game the fun stopped we started playing
this [ __ ] game I don't even remember
the game but it was like some game where
we had to guess some [ __ ] and we were
like wait this is this was us the rest
of the [ __ ] will okay uh and she and
then finally she was like I didn't mean
to stop the fun we were crying our eyes
out laughing and then you want to play a
game dude we're figuring out how the
[ __ ] we are
[ __ ] me how do you want to
[ __ ] play a guessing game by turn
round get out the plane we were on a
plane hey here's a parachute you gonna
play a game on the plane
here's parachute you know play a game on
the ground let's take a flight up to the
air here's a parachute
huh [ __ ] I I just I want to be a
politician so bad so they can expose
[ __ ] about me and then I can be on a
[ __ ] you have a conference meeting
and be like here's what I have to say
about that me flipsie and they're like
president delay is losing his mind and
I'm like no I'm not dude
[ __ ] I'm me you want a hoop
president D'Elia nope I'm me and that's
my that's my inauguration song
I wish Lil Wayne didn't do so many drugs
cuz he's so good dude remember when he
is like meta female dragon dude that's
so III remember hahaha I thought about
it for so long like about like a [ __ ]
up if you really did that would be news
you know like it would be in the news if
you may imagine Lil Wayne actually
meeting a female dragon like oh [ __ ]
Andrew a female Rio Jews love a son is
like lasagna like house even think of
that [ __ ] and then they [ __ ] it all up
with Birdman going you know kids
hahaha kids I don't know man okay let's
do Reed's yeah this episode of 81 do are
we doing I love you guys to it me undies
you've heard me talk about me on these a
million times but why am I actually so
obsessed with them I'll tell you why
dude when I wake up in the morning I'm
groggy alright I don't want some days I
told you I woke up sad some days I put
on me on these it's the start to feeling
better they they're fabric that they use
is unreal you have to experience it I am
not lying to you just because this is an
ad doesn't mean I'm not serious
III get behind products that I I like
and I use and I care about me undies is
awesome alright I wear the patterns I
want to wear it's fun for me they got
different crazy prints and they also got
plain colors go look they use micro moto
fabric which is a full three times
softer than regular cotton you have to
feel it to believe it I'm telling you
dude it's the fabric you're gonna want
down there in your privates
100% satisfaction guarantee you'll love
the undies but if there's anything that
you're not into about it you just send
them back for a full refund to get your
15% off your first pair free shipping
and a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee go to me on DS comm slash
Congrats that's me andis calm slash
Congrats they launched a brand new
membership you can level up your top
drawer with new undies each month
members gain access to exclusive prints
that no one else can get they get
special member pricing on every product
me undies makes and you can switch
styles or skip any month you want post
mates used it last night used it the
night before used it the night before
that I use it literally every day you
know what's great about eating your
favorite thing it's your favorite thing
and you're eating it you know it's not
great getting it and the only friend and
the only fast thing that deliver are not
what you're craving okay but this here
post makes change all that the app that
adds a delivery option to your favorite
restaurants they'll pick it up from your
rip from from the restaurant you want
imagine anything you want to eat
delivered you don't have to drive parked
or even talk on the phone to order
download the app and order 24 hours a
day 365 days a year post mates will
bring you what you want within the hour
you can even see where your food is and
track your driver also do you forget
eggs and milk snow problem craving tasty
burger check looking for the perfect
bottle of red wine or a summer beer or
order up for limited time post mates is
giving you $100 of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app today and
use code Congrats
that's code congrats for 100 off free
delivery of free delivery credit for
your first 7 days save the hassle get
the food you love fast at post mates
with the code congrats scarce square
cash
the cash at you know the cash app it's
the simplest way to instantly send money
to friends
it's the also number one app in finance
the cash card is free customizable debit
card you can use at stores or ATMs it's
linked to your cash app balance as if it
were a checking account it even lets you
direct deposit your paycheck if you're
looking for an alternative to
traditional banking you're not alone
millions of Americans have already
started using the cash card there's
never been a rewards program like boosts
get instant discounts every single time
you swipe your cash card at coffee shops
Chipotle Shake Shack and beyond just tap
a boost in the app and pay with your
cash card cash app is also the most
convenient and inexpensive way to buy
sell and withdraw Bitcoin twenty years
ago something like cash app would have
been hard to imagine now it's hard to
imagine anything else and of course when
you download the cash app and into
rewards code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market I
just think you know I just think that I
just think that you got it figure out
the why you figure no it's alright dude
who cares it's my [ __ ] computer I get
an email it reminds me the bit I did on
my [ __ ] new special coming out I
wonder what I'm going to call it I don't
know what I'm going to call it yeah on
Netflix they want me to talk entitle it
ah man loving it loving it loving it
loving it but yeah I would never turn
myself into it if I did some crime
such a cute doggie by the way my dog my
ivan get rid of his dog looks like ivan
get rid of they have the same beard come
here no okay cool good boy dude I used
to have a dog named Hank and Jo koy
would come over and every time jo koy
would come over Hank would never go near
new people so Jo
so Joker would be like come here buddy
and he wouldn't move and then he'd say
good boy
I was funny dude oh [ __ ] I'm excited to
get on the road I've been here for I did
this [ __ ] benefit last night this kid
this kid died dude and they're trying to
have a foundation forum or something so
it's always so weird doing a comedy show
about like something like you know it's
like to raise the money it was great but
God it's just somber vibe I try to say
yes to a lot of those let me tell you
something to you guys I I really
appreciate all the support that you guys
give me I'm a man the way that you guys
listen to the podcast and the way you
guys support it and send me tweets and
all that [ __ ] it means a lot sometimes
you know a lot of times I like slamming
people online if they say negative stuff
about me and I'll search my name even
not just the tags and I'll slam them
back because I have a great day doing it
cuz you know cuz it's fun for me
and you know how it goes right but I
just [ __ ] I have a I have a lot of
love for you guys doing that and man my
my aunt told me the funniest [ __ ]
story anyway I just want to say thank
you but my aunt told me the funniest
[ __ ] story about my mmm my cousin
we were we were watching it well I was
actually there so we were watching a
show once and somebody said my cousin
was real young but he was we were
watching a show we were all kids and but
I was old enough to know about sex and
stuff and on the show it said somebody
said the word boner dude you're gonna
love this one fire and she was and and
he he just goes mom what's a boner and
then she said I'll tell you later he
says no no no I said boner what's a
boner come on tell me he's like I'll
tell you later he was like man come on
tell me what a boner is and we and
everyone was like [ __ ] laughing he's
like I'll tell you later
and so she told him later and he's like
mom what's a boner and she was like okay
so it's when all the blood rushes to
your penis and you know you you're and
it gets and your penis gets hard you
know she tried to explain as best as she
could as a mom and it was around the
time where you know people started
talking about boners and learn about
boners and and and and you know you sort
of get the age where you getting boners
and then a few weeks later he was what
she said he walked through the kitchen
and was like well mom all the Bloods
rushing to my penis Bloods rushing to my
penis mom oh [ __ ] dude she told me this
story we were crying I don't know how we
didn't hear that story Bloods rushing to
my penis mom how funny is that do it
just little kids all the Bloods rushing
to my penis
dad my cousin when he was younger he had
a funny little voice like he sounded
like this and he was going like this and
he would go oh you're my croissant man
he would always say will you make me so
mad like that was how we let his
frustration out like would just be like
oh yeah my got me so mad and dude we
would laugh my brother and I we laugh we
would spell met ma Yad man I remember
one time my brother was doing his
homework in his room and I was in my
room supposed to be doing my homework
and I kept saying oh you're making me
sound mad and I mom was trying to help
my brother do his homework and she got
so mad at me I know she was like stop
doing that and I was like by tamiya
and my brother was crying laughing and
he wouldn't do his homework because he
was laughing so hard I got so much
trouble dude dude kids are [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah I was such a dick one time I
call my mom a [ __ ] when I was a young
young kid I barely oh my god I like I
mean I got grounded I got so grounded
there's the only time I think well
there's only time I ever called her that
I mean god what an [ __ ] kid she was
like she was like get to shoot but do oh
by the way I was never late for school
ever in my life never was I ever late
for school
never do you understand me I was never
late for school ever once I'm telling
you every [ __ ] morning dude get up
you're gonna be late
every [ __ ] morning Chris yep yet
you're gonna be late come on I was never
once late for school
come on Chris you're gonna be late get
up mom I'm never late just start
shower yet no I'll never late I'll be
fine
it's too early come on always with that
[ __ ] tone come on like talking to a
[ __ ] dog trying to get through it
come on you start the shower yet and
sometimes a wooden answer hoping that
she would think that I was in the shower
do you start to shower yet I was never
late one day one day I was so just
thinking about how I was never late and
I thought that the [ __ ] and I thought
that the shower turning on would drown
out my little an idiot I was so tired
but I turned on the shower and I didn't
even call
I actually technically didn't even call
her a [ __ ] I was saying [ __ ] after the
sentence I said I'm starting the shower
and then I said [ __ ] I stand by that I
did not call her a [ __ ]
but of course it sounded like it I wanna
[ __ ] and I did and I said I started
the shower [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then just my dad was like hey you're
grounded and I was like yeah I know I
was never late for school even after
that was never late for school dude I
never ditched class until my senior year
one time I did I live one or two times I
ditched after I got into college at like
a ditch like Hall Mac or some [ __ ] never
ditched class I was a cut-up in class I
make fun of everybody but like never did
I [ __ ] ditch my parents didn't cut me
slack on that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's some
[ __ ] first world problem on some
white privilege [ __ ] right it's weird
being a [ __ ] white guy you can't you
can't complain about anything dude III
was actually thinking about like some
guy I was thinking about how
somebody was like saying they didn't
like my comedy because I was a [ __ ]
bro which is actually uh prejudice cuz
I'm so not a bro if you know anything
about me like I'm so not a bro I'm not a
frat guy I mean you guys all know this
cuz you listen to me and you support me
and I [ __ ] love you for it
but like an idiot would see me and be
like ah that's [ __ ] bro
he's a bro I'm not they're just saying
that they're being prejudiced because
I'm at all [ __ ] long-haired
broad-shouldered [ __ ] right ok
and and I get it I get I look like the
guy who would [ __ ] hit your girl up I
get that dude I get it and I was
thinking about this guy on Twitter was
saying something and I was like dude he
doesn't understand and and he doesn't
know me and I was thinking about what if
I [ __ ] complained about that like
what if I had a [ __ ] documentary
about like how like dude it's hard
because people don't understand because
like like it's funny cuz it's like an
actual annoying thing in my life but
like I can't complain about it because
like I'm six-two I'm a comedian
I [ __ ] I'm successful but like
everybody has problems but it's [ __ ]
up if you're deemed somebody who doesn't
have problems you can't come out and say
oh I have problems cuz you sound like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I get it and I get it
and I [ __ ] you can't you just gotta
shut the [ __ ] up I'm a white guy I can't
come out and say I can't start talking
about the things that frustrate me in my
life cuz I sound like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but that's actually a problem you know
it really is like all these marginalized
people have the real problems
quote-unquote and that's true that's
true
I have practically no problems I get it
dude
I get it but I can't talk about you know
the things that I do have because there
are real problems in the world and I
understand that and there are look if I
was gonna fix problems in the world I
wouldn't fix my problems first I'd fix
[ __ ] to other people's problems first
because there are big problems but
these marginalized people and these
groups that form they want to be
inclusive but it's making everybody the
opposite you know like the second you
say we're a group we want this then the
other groups are going to form and say
yeah but you can't have that because we
want this it's an impossible [ __ ]
thing to figure out I actually think it
might be impossible being human and to
give up that tribal mentality because
you know we all want what we want but we
don't want what we don't want dude
that's that's we don't want what we
don't want more than we do when we want
we want you know so that's how you get
like you know fascists and anti-fur I
think because it's like I'm Emma way too
dumb to be talking about this but dude
the and we talk about this a lot or I
talk about this a lot but the Liberals
they're become they become what they
hate and I love how like people are like
like I bash [ __ ] Republic I don't
bash Republicans I just - dummies right
and I think a lot of Republicans are
dummies just like a lot of Democrats are
dummies but the second I bash anybody
who seems to be or is Republican people
are like oh Hollywood's get into you
you're a liberal elite no I'll do it I'm
not I'm not dude I'm not liberal I'm not
Republican I'm not [ __ ] the Democrat
I'm not I'm not conservative I don't
give a [ __ ] dude it I'm a comedian
that's what I am dude so I'm not like
I'm Way too dumb to come up with
something that's gonna fix a problem or
whatever I complain in a funny way
that's what I do
but the second it gets to complaining
about my life
is when you say oh [ __ ] well what does
he know man he's a white guy he doesn't
get the real struggle whatever is a [ __ ]
I have a good life it's fine I'm happy
right
my idiot buddy is like I don't care
about I don't care who's the president
it never affects me he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you got a [ __ ] you got a you got a
care all I know is that [ __ ] Michael
Douglas from behind the candelabra looks
like my goddamn grandma and that's
[ __ ] crazy
sometimes I do feel guilty though about
how I don't stand for [ __ ] you know like
I try to I try to be a good person and
help certain people you know if they ask
friends and [ __ ] like that but like III
don't stand for [ __ ] and that's weird
the only thing I stand for is like say
what you want in a funny way and like
don't be offended if you're offended and
that's your problem you know but like
I've lived my life I've let my lysse
that's the thing about being a white guy
is you can let yourself live the easiest
way possible but you can't necessarily
if you're not a white guy right you can
make your life so easy it's ridiculous
you can let your life be so easy it's
ridiculous right and then that can take
over your life and and and it can become
who you are like and then and then
I don't know I guess because you're a
white guy you can stay no I don't know
anything about this [ __ ] privilege
[ __ ] I wish I could I wish I knew I wish
I [ __ ] I don't know do I though you
know how people are like I always wish I
played the pan I always wish I learned
that any instrument I wish I read more I
wish I why yeah you know it's like yeah
I get it cool you know like like people
like like I imagine like if I were ever
on Real Time with Bill Moore I could
never do I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about I don't know what
the [ __ ] they're ever talking about and
but I don't care I don't it's not that I
don't care it's that I don't ever want
to be in those canoes discussions like
dude I was talking my families we talk
about we just lately have been talking
about politics a lot and it just makes
me sad man there's so much [ __ ]
going on in the world it just makes me
sad all I want to do is [ __ ] laugh
man all I want to do is laugh that's all
I [ __ ] ever wanted to do is laugh so
that's [ __ ] privilege is that I get
to do that I don't know [ __ ] is so funny
though if you think about it if you find
a way to make it [ __ ] funny you know
let's do some questions
well yeah but also that's wrong okay
keep going
this guy imagine rushing home to sit on
the couch to watch a golf tournament huh
here's the other thing Griz every letter
every word in his thing is capitalized
who does that why would you do that it
takes extra time yo imagine rushing home
the the why the I the our and rushing
the H in home they're all capitalized
why are you doing that
that's what Jaden Smith doesn't why do
people do that that's not gonna if you
were an alien and you were dressed up as
a and you and you were coming to take
over the world and you've had a human
suit you'd do that and because you
didn't get it why do you do that why
would you do that
uh hey Krista Leah what do you order
when you get disrespectful on those
babies offers for eating
I already usually balls you know nothing
like a [ __ ] ball with some quinoa
brown rice or uh some chicken or some
guacamole you know I get bowls dude or
I'll get some [ __ ] salmon from tender
greens it was another one oh no dude
Posey at to [ __ ] Chris Leah when
somebody gets in your [ __ ] way on the
sidewalk or whatever do you [ __ ] Leigh
turn sideways oh I get it or shoulder
check them no dude it's not I mean you
can [ __ ] chili turn sideways but dude
if you shoulder check somebody on the
sidewalk which has happened to me before
it's like you're a [ __ ] ass one guy
did that to me once in San Francisco he
had a full blue suit on he looked like
he was one of the kings of comedy and
dude it was so hard and I we weren't eat
we were just on the sidewalk we could
have moved uh I I actually did try to
move out of the way and he still
shoulder checked me and I laughed and he
didn't turn back around I look around a
little what the [ __ ] dude San Francisco
is hell on earth I've seen these are the
things I've seen in San Francisco I saw
a guy [ __ ] on the street I saw a guy
piss in between two mailboxes I saw
three people crying in their car I saw a
guy slam a door once so hard at a checks
cash checks cash place a glass door that
it broke
I saw another guy walk in front of a bus
and stop it I saw I got guys getting
arrested and I actually for real saw two
guys [ __ ] in the ass on the street on
the street on their knees on their knees
in San Francisco it's hell on earth
I saw all that you're telling me I
didn't see all that I saw it all
oh also once when I was on stage a guy
threw an envelope on stage and I opened
it after the show and there were
mushrooms inside
oh it's hell on earth
she said the owner of the club was like
thank God you didn't open it on stage
she's we would've had to call the cops
and get the guy arrested how crazy would
that have been
yeah when I understand I understand that
because like you can't just let that
should slide in your establishment if
you know what's going down and I was
like hey what the [ __ ] there's
psilocybin mushrooms how crazy would
have that been on stage
hey at chrisley on the junior on the Joe
Rogan experience a few years back you
talked about being all in on one thing
at a time then moving on to the next
thing
yeah yeah how did you finally find the
balance I don't do it my thing is
stand-up I do it all the time and then I
have another thing too which is working
out I'm very into but that's it that's
all I do that's all I [ __ ] do that's
all I want to do besides that I think a
ridiculous [ __ ] in my head and then I'll
say it on stage so that's kind of
stand-up I don't want to [ __ ] you
know it's just it's hard I remember
reading an article once about Jon
Favreau and he was like dude it's hard
for me to do two projects and once I do
one project at a time but that's what he
said at least um yeah I like to [ __ ]
do one thing at a time cuz I'm all in I
don't know that's always how I think
it's my OCD about that I'm not one of
those guys to that psych oh my god I
have OCD like [ __ ] people do that
chicks do it a lot they're like yeah I
have OCD oh my god
I reckon I like putting I love keeping
all my pens in my backpack and you're
like yeah that's not OCD OCD is thinking
you're gonna [ __ ] die in a train
wreck if you don't stack the plates
right you know one of these days I'll
talk about that and open up about that a
little bit more but it's a comedy
podcast gotta keep it light I don't know
but that's it man I don't really have
too much [ __ ] other [ __ ] to talk about
I guess that's about it we got is this
up are we ready to do these we got new
merch coming too much tomorrow tomorrow
Wednesday which means it'll be [ __ ]
Friday cuz one fire this week we got new
merch and it's really some special [ __ ]
you got a chick keep checking my website
I will tweet it too but it's some good
[ __ ] dude I'm really excited about it's
been a long time since I've been this
excited about a new [ __ ] shirt coming
out do it it's hot as [ __ ] man and you
know when you wear this [ __ ]
[ __ ] are [ __ ] know
what the deal is I can't I don't want to
give too much away I've shot you know
but you'll see when we drop this [ __ ]
it's hot it's hot it's hot as [ __ ] so
download the cash app for free at the
App Store or Google Play market enter
rewards code Congrats get $5 give $5 -
times up
yep new design coming this week follow
the leader
buy tickets on Chris D'Elia calm for
might or follow-the-leader Wichita
Kansas Kansas City Lincoln Reno Las
Vegas Ottawa Ontario London Ontario
Buffalo Burlington Vermont Philadelphia
Washington DC New York Montclair
Portland Snoqualmie Vancouver Miami West
Palm Beach Jacksonville Atlanta Los
Angeles San Francisco Boston Fresno
Bakersfield Austin San Antonio subscribe
to the YouTube channel the videos come
out every other Tuesday or Tuesday or
Wednesday download the Chris D'Elia app
do that so you could watch my podcast
live for iOS or Android subscribe rate
and review the show tweet me by using
the handle at congrats Bob or using the
hashtag congratulations pot and that's
about it guys are great thank you very
much
[Music]